are you Asian yeah I'm just I was
looking at you and I said that dunno huh
when I'm on the road baby what do I say
when I'm on the road I call her I go
like I go he's putting a shop over to
the house you are you attracted to
Brennan it's okay yeah I know but I
think that there's something going on so
I was like call her over do you think he
would know if there was something going
on you know I trust him but it's just
that women love him they look at him and
they want with him I know yeah they're
your [ __ ] handsome boy innocent
well after we did the fight companion
together yeah I think we exchanged
messages on Twitter once and that was it
and you you you you saw that and all of
it just grew in your head to be
something it should happen I did the
fight companion and then I didn't seen
him in a while and that's um at the
Comedy Store and I said hey Brendan and
then he goes uh you go for the Todd
anyway that was his opening line yeah
what's up yeah you know and they it was
planning a CNN you know could I say
something if you if I was on the road
and Brendan Schaub came over here and
drilled you and stuff like that just
listen to say drilled again it's drilled
basically different I would be really
angry with you but I think that I I
don't know what I would do because I
could crush me no you'd be you'd also be
a little understanding huh dude you look
here about the launch Korean missile
take it easy
I have HR s Han no hidden [ __ ]
strength yeah yes I do
haha and I'm stronger they're not help
me Jon I will break your cheekbones with
my eyes don't do it
I don't ever talk to me like that man
I'm not a [ __ ] pansy dude how much am
I getting paid for this [ __ ] but
nothing not a seriously no publish
publish I have the square you know how
this happened that is so so good I see I
know what a great sticker all right let
me show to you wouldn't kill him to trim
a little bit no you know what I really
like the whole animalistic women don't
give a [ __ ] I don't like the trimming it
chafes it's a anytime a guy is very very
well-groomed he's spending way too much
time in himself and that's unattractive
to me yeah yeah I like the dirty kind of
disheveled just rolled out of bed I have
a little machete I give girls to get
through to that you know well you have a
little machete that I give girls and
they get to the promised land
it's pronounced isn't it perhaps much
much more in the car yeah yeah something
Monica how's your dick I got a [ __ ]
angry piece yeah it's got a bend to him
No
[Music]